في معهد سكريبس لعلوم
المحيطات، يقوم ثلاثة علماء
من تخصصات مختلفة بجمع
بيانات مهمة من نفس
المصدر والمثير للدهشة إلى حد ما
[ضحك]
تخبرك الفقاعات بكل شيء تركز
كيمياء الغلاف الجوي كيمبرلي براذر
على كيفية تأثير النشاط البشري على
الغلاف الجوي والمناخ الخاص بنا.
الصحة أحد أكبر الأسئلة هو
ما كان يفعله الكوكب قبل
ظهور البشر ولا يمكننا الإجابة على ذلك
في الوقت الحالي. لقد أمضى عالم المحيطات جرانت دين
حياته المهنية في دراسة دور
المحيط في الطقس والمناخ،
واهتمامي ينصب في المقام الأول على ما يقرب من 20
أقدام من ارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر محبوسة في
الغطاء الجليدي في جرينلاند، يركز
عالم المناخ القديم جيفري سيفيرنجهاوس
على الغازات الدفيئة المحاصرة
في الجليد الجليدي خاصة من
القارة القطبية الجنوبية، نعم، هذا ما
تبدو عليه نواة الجليد،
وسأقوم بتقطيعها قليلاً
حتى تتمكن من ذلك  انظر حقًا إلى الفقاعات
الخاصة بالباحثين الثلاثة المشهورين،
الفقاعات تحمل المفتاح لفتح
ثروة، معلومات قد تكون رائدة،
إنها حقًا وفرة من الأشياء التي
يمكنك تعلمها من فقاعات الهواء التي وجدناها
جليدًا يعود تاريخه إلى ثلاثة ملايين سنة الآن
نعم بجدية نعم نعم هذا
رائع، لذلك نحن نعرف ما
كان تركيز ثاني أكسيد الكربون قبل ثلاثة ملايين سنة.
يقول سيفيرينغهاوس إن الحصول على هذا النوع
من البيانات من الماضي يخبرنا بمدى
ارتفاع درجة حرارة البشر في المناخ اليوم،
وفي الوقت نفسه، فإن أحد مجالات تركيز جرانت دين
هو استخدام المراقبة الصوتية
لقياس  ذوبان الجليد، وهي عملية
تنتج كمية كبيرة من الفقاعات،
سأقوم بتشغيل مقطع صوتي لما تبدو عليه
هذه العين الجليدية أثناء ذوبانها، حيث تسمع
كل أصوات الفرقعة مثل
قلي لحم الخنزير المقدد، والتي تكون مفعمة
بالحيوية حقًا مثل الألعاب النارية التي تنطلق من كل
واحدة منها  من تلك الملوثات العضوية الثابتة هي فقاعة تنفجر
من الجليد في الماء،
نحتاج إلى حساب تلك الفقاعات، إذا تمكنا من عدها،
يمكننا معرفة مقدار
ذوبان الجليد، وهذا أمر مهم لأن
الكثير من حضارتنا تقع في
المناطق الساحلية
بالنسبة لكيمبرلي براذر.  كل شيء عن
جزيئات الهباء الجوي والكائنات الحية الدقيقة
التي تنفجر من الفقاعات التي تتشكل عن طريق
الأمواج المتكسرة المعروفة باسم رذاذ البحر وكيف
يمكن لهذا التفاعل أن يساعد في
تدفئة الكوكب أو تبريده، لذلك كنا
نحاول إلقاء نظرة على العلاقة بين
الميكروبات والماء  وكيف
تغير الكيمياء أنا كيميائي
ثم كيف تغير هذه الكيمياء ما
يخرج وكيف يغير ذلك كيفية
تشكل السحب وهكذا تعلم أنك تنظر
إلى المحيطات وتعرف أنها ثلاثة
أرباع أرضنا وبدون تلك
السحب نحن  "إننا في ورطة
في هذا اليوم وهي في خضم
إدارة حملة البحث الأولى على
آلة متطورة تسمى القروح، وهي
محاكاة أبحاث الغلاف الجوي للمحيطات من سكريبس مصممة لتكرار العواصف المحيطية،
يمكننا أن نفهم كيف يعدل هذا الرذاذ
الأعاصير، ثم يمكننا
البدء في التفكير  حول هل يمكننا إيقاف
الإعصار قبل أن يضرب الأرض، نعم، هذه هي
الفكرة الجامحة ولكن يمكننا فعل ذلك، ساعد
دين في تطوير القروح كجسر
بين المختبر والمحيط المفتوح مما
يوفر وسيلة مهمة للتحكم
وإمدادًا لا نهاية له من الفقاعات، إنها
إمكانية  تغيير قواعد اللعبة الذي سيساعد
العلماء على فهم الكوكب
بطرق غير مسبوقة
عندما أخبر الناس أن أحد
الأشياء التي أعمل عليها هي الفقاعات في المحيط،
رد الفعل هو هل أنت جاد، إنها
حقًا دراسة علمية جادة ولكن
اتضح أن الفقاعات خطيرة للغاية
أعمال جادة
أجنبية